Speaker 1: Okay. A couple of other quick stories
that we've been covering. The Alex Jones text
messages have made their way to the Trump Riot
Committee based on reporting from a number of
different sources. So let's back up and remind
you what's going on. We knew before the Alex
Jones defamation trial that Jones was involved and
in contact with people that were organizing. And
at the Trump riots on January six, 2021, we knew
that it would be great if Alex Jones was somehow
more involved and under scrutiny from the
January six committee, but it wasn't clear if
and how that was going to happen. Then the Alex
Jones defamation trial took place, and as you
might remember, Alex Jones own boneheaded lawyer
accidentally sent a full digital copy of Jones
entire mobile phone, including text messages
and other things to the attorney representing
the plaintiffs in the defamation trial. And
there was cartoonish stuff in there. Like,
for example, there was a record of Alex Jones
sending. According to the plaintiff's attorney,
Alex Jones sent a naked picture of his own wife
to Roger Stone, like bizarre, cartoonish stuff,
but also because of the timeline of those text
messages and that digital copy. It was reasonable
to believe or to expect or to wonder that
materials related to January six also would have
been on that digital copy. And then we learned
the January six committee wants Alex Jones text
messages. And now the reporting from CNN is Alex
Jones. Texts have been turned over to the January
six committee. The article reads Approximately two
years worth of text messages sent and received by
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones have been
turned over to the House Select Committee
investigating the January 6th insurrection, a
person familiar with the matter said to CNN.
The messages were handed over to the committee
by Marc Bankston, the attorney who represented
the Sandy Hook parents who successfully sued
Jones in Texas and won nearly $50 million in
the civil trial. Bankston would only tell CNN
that he is cooperating with the committee.
The committee declined to comment during the
trial. As you might recall, Bankston revealed one
of Jones lawyers messed up and inadvertently sent
him the two years of text messages that Bankston
and Bankston also said during the trial. The
committee expressed interest in the material.
You know, it's a really good thing that so many of
the people behind January 6th involved in January
six and in this case representing individuals
involved with January 6th, speaking, of course, of
Alex Jones, attorney, are kind of dufus. It's very
useful. And it aids the investigation to proceed
that a lot of these people don't seem
to be playing with a full deck or,
you know, the wheel is spinning, but the hamsters
dead, whatever metaphor or phrase you want to
apply to it. Now, none of this means that there
are going to be consequences. I think, as we now
have learned of the FBI raid of Donald Trump's
Mar a Lago home. It's entertaining. It feels
like at least he's suffering a little because
they raided his home. But I am not assuming
that Trump is going to be indicted or that if he
is, that there will be consequences. We will have
to wait and see. And similarly, the fact that the
committee now has the text messages of Alex Jones,
even though it was not Jones intention for the
committee to have them, it doesn't necessarily
mean that there's going to be consequences. Now,
one of the things that is important to remember
is any time you're dealing with leaks or
transfers of information, the right wingers
love to pull this double standard. When it came
to the Hunter Biden laptop, they didn't care how
the blind computer tech got it. They didn't
care about anything in terms of due process
or discovery or finding. It didn't matter. It
was what's on the laptop. Now they're saying,
well, hold on a second. What about due process?
This was an accident. What about attorney client
privilege? What about invasion of privacy? What
about free speech? They'll throw whatever they
can at the wall to say the content of the text
messages does not matter. All that matters is
how did the January six committee obtain the
text messages? Predictable people. We will
see what happens and what the next step is in
terms of the committee and Alex Jones, remember
the committee expected to hold more hearings, I
believe they said, in September. So we will see